after a long night of vote suspense the
social Democrats and its allies managed
to secure 90 seats in the parliament the
results paved the way for prime minister
Mata Frederickson to form a new
government
care Denmark
I'm so proud
we are a party for all of Denmark
one of the biggest winners in the
election are the moderates the party
formed by former prime minister last
Luka Rasmussen five months ago is now
the third largest political party in the
country
foreign we have made it to Parliament
where we will make our presence
the social liberals have triggered the
snap elections lost half of the seats
they had in 2019. they now stand at
eight
the center right venstra was one of the
biggest losers the selection is its
worst performance in 30 years but the
far right has done well particularly the
new right and the Denmark's Democrats
who have expanded their Base by pushing
a hard line on immigration the election
was dominated by climate Rising
inflation and costs of living people
here want to see the government preserve
the country's welfare state one of the
most generous in the world
both Frederickson and Rasmussen agree at
Centris Coalition will ensure stability
and put an end to the outside's role
that small parties have been playing
over many years but it's too early to
tell whether the prime minister is
willing to make enough concessions to
convince the moderates to join her
government Copenhagen